joining us now is cbs news chief
washington correspondent that's
major garrett major garrett good morning
to you we're down to the final stretch
have you heard of a focused closing
argument from the president
on what he intends to do a second term
we i know we've heard a lot of attacks
we've heard a lot of name
name calling can you help us understand
the strategy here
there is one that is forming and you
heard a little bit of it in that
response to leslie stahl the president
saying i want america to get back to a
normal life gail i can tell you this for
the last six to eight weeks
pollsters and strategists with the trump
reelection campaign have begged the
president to talk in these terms
that if you reelect me america i'll get
you back to your normal life the
president essentially set
all that advice aside until this week
where a couple of
people he's very very familiar with dave
bosses deputy campaign manager from
2016.
corey lewandowski his first campaign
manager back in 2015 and 2016
were brought back much more aggressively
into the campaign
nexus and they sat the president down
and said you've got to talk about two
things
getting america back to normal and that
joe biden and his agenda will kill the
american dream you're beginning to see
the formation of that closing argument
but it's awfully late in the campaign
and the president's wasted a lot of time
ignoring the advice he could have taken
weeks before
following up on norah's interview with
joe biden there he does seem to
appear to be leaving the door open to
adding more justices to the supreme
court
do voters care about this issue major
not really
republicans tell me all the polling data
they see doesn't really move the needle
very much they thought it would but it
doesn't but here's the real
important part of what the former vice
president said a commission in
washington that means you're punting
that means you're setting it off
for democrats the key issue is electing
joe biden not only that but winning a
senate democratic majority and changing
the rules
so if anything happens at the supreme
court with roe versus wade
same-sex marriage or the affordable care
act with 51 votes in a democratically
controlled senate you can change the law
and fix whatever the supreme court
overrules that is where the minds and
the strategic impulse
and imperative of senate democrats and
everyone in the democratic party is
right now not
enlarging the court winning the senate
winning the presidency
big debate tonight the conventional
thinking is that most people have
already made up their minds
but i'm wondering with the undecided
voters is this race and i know you know
people on both sides
is this race closer than it appears to
be certainly the trump people believe
that it is they discount
every pollster except their own and they
believe that there is a hidden
shy trump vote of worth anywhere between
two points to four points depending on
the battleground state
that's simply not detected and they know
where it is and nobody else does
but they also do not expect as every
analyst i've talked to does
record turnout of 150 million 155
million if turnout is that much bigger
the big problem for the trump campaign
is can you find all those new voters
democrats believe they can
the trump campaign believes possibly it
can
but they may not have as many voters as
they assume
the polls are not detecting all right
major thank you very much
cbs news will bring you tonight's final
presidential debate with live primetime
coverage
starting at nine o'clock eastern six
o'clock pacific right here on cbs